[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
a suspect charged with shooting eight
people at three massage parlors across
georgia
the alleged motive revealed by
authorities an issue with porn
and that he was attempting to take out
that temptation
another delay in the trial of
millionaire real estate heir robert
durst
accused of murdering his best friend
susan berman what's in a letter the
defendant mailed to the judge
and sentencing for the admitted murderer
of bianca devins the time brandon clark
will spend in prison
for posting pictures of the victim's
body on social media my entire adult
life i enjoy
his mom without her i don't know who i
am
plus two jurors in the derek shoving
trial excused after they were selected
why they say they no longer can be fair
and impartial following the 27 million
dollar settlement to the family of
george floyd
my gut reaction to that again with the
dollar amount being high
law on crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
jury selection has been slow while
moving forward in the trial against
derek shovin
long crime's kim johnson is in
minneapolis for us and is here to
explain how the court took two steps
back
towards seating a jury yeah brian it's
been a
pivotal day in the derek chauvin trial
after two seated jurors were
kicked off the trial saying that they
could no longer be
impartial the reason is that
announcement of a 27 million dollar
settlement between the city of
minneapolis and the family of george
floyd
after being brought back to court by a
zoom two of the jurors said that they
could no longer be impartial
after hearing about the settlement
listen to what one had to say when
questioned by the judge
that dollar amount was kind of shocking
to me that
kind of sent a message that the city of
minneapolis felt that something was
wrong
and they wanted to make it right to the
tune of that dollar amount
um i think in the headline if it would
have said
two thousand dollars versus twenty
million um that's a big change so i
think that that sticker price obviously
shocked me um and and kind of swayed me
a little bit yes
the two jurors dismissed a hispanic man
in his
20s and a white man in his 30s both
mentioned the large dollar amount a
record
for minneapolis as a reason for swaying
their opinion
the remaining jurors re-questioned
promised to remain impartial and agreed
they could set aside news of the payout
and just focus on the evidence
presented in court now a new juror
has been seated in this trial that
brings a total to eight
14 are needed including two alternates
so jury selection continues on thursday
even though
judge peter cahill could still move this
trial
or reschedule it in the wake of the city
payout to the floyd state brian
thanks kim the prosecution asked one
potential juror a black male in his 40s
how he views someone who uses illegal
drugs he was selected
to serve someone might say that if
someone
is taking illegal drugs and they're
harmed
they have only themselves to blame for
that too what do you think of that
statement
uh i would disagree with that i mean if
i said disagree
meaning like you you are on drug
then something happened to you right uh
it's a tough one but i i think
i'll be neutral and i'm not blaming
anybody first i mean
still we just still have to go with the
fact you know
joining us today is the founder of trial
methods alan turkheimer alan
pleasure to have you but let's jump
right in can we start by i don't know
you giving us your professional opinion
of what you see from
either side and maybe assigning a grade
to uh to both sides
i'm looking at some of the reasons why
jurors are being excluded for cause or
peremptories and i think each side is
doing exactly what they have to if you
think about it if you
if the defense likes a juror the
prosecution's going to get rid of that
juror and vice versa so
i'm looking at this as a question of
jury deselection where you have a finite
number of people
and each side is coming in getting
candid responses from a lot of the
jurors and then realizing oh this
person's going to be too biased
and i think both sides are getting rid
of those that they absolutely have to
get rid of so i think each side is doing
a good job of trying to
get rid of those negatively disposed to
their k so far
and in terms of a grade what would you
do like a b are they doing really well
or just kind of good
i think they're doing pretty well you
know i don't i'd like to be sitting in
there and uh seeing the facial
expressions and and getting more
information and
tying their uh responses to what they
filled out in the questionnaire but
overall i think each side is doing a
nice job and it looks like it's
gonna be a more diverse jury than
hennepin county and i think that usually
proves for a better more
rich volatile deliberation where more
viewpoints are considered and
things are recalled more accurately
sounds good let's bring in co-host terry
austin terry
what do you make of the judge's decision
to bring in seven of the nine jurors
and ultimately excuse two you know what
brian
judge cahill is doing his best to
salvage this case he called these jurors
back
and he asked them about this settlement
and whether it would influence them
and he kicked out two of them who said
that it would
influence them you know there was a very
similar case back in 2019
in the city of minneapolis where they
paid a 20 million dollar
settlement it was the north case and
they did that right
before the jury came back but they
waited
to announce the settlement and i think
they should have done that here because
it's making it
very difficult to get a fair and
impartial jury and i think the judge is
really doing his best to try to make
sure that he gets a fair jury and that
we don't get a mistrial or have to
delay the trial in any way now alan only
two alternates that sounds
crazy right and uh i know you already
kind of touched on it a little but if
you have any
just a little tidbit of advice uh as a
consultant in this case what would you
give
you're right two alternates isn't that
much and uh back to what you were
talking about i'm just gonna say that
phones automatically give updates so
it's not as if the jurors did anything
wrong
they could just pick up their phone and
see 27 million dollars
but um two alternates is not that that
much at all and maybe the judge will
revisit it
it's uh obviously a long trial and you
know but
with what people have going on in the
world and especially on the tail end of
the pandemic
i think that maybe the judge should
reconsider and see more than just two
alternates
yeah and they'll probably have a lot of
time as well because it looks like they
may get to that
number of 14 sooner rather than later
alan turkey thank you very much
uh terry we'll see you in a moment be
sure to tune in to the law and crime
network for gavel to gamble coverage of
the derrick chauvin trial
in the murder of george floyd still
ahead on law and crime daily
the letter millionaire real estate heir
robert durst wants the trial judge to
see
but first the sentence of a man accused
of killing a 17 year old girl
in a way that shocked even our experts
the case you may not want to see
but gotta hear next
we're back a man who admitted to
slitting a teenage girl's throat and
posting photos of the murder on social
media
learns his punishment law and crime's
angina laby has the emotional words
from bianca devin's family at her
killer's sentencing
brian bianca denvins was only 17 years
old when she was murdered
her mother and her younger sister told
the court what brandon clark's actions
have done to their family brandon clark
walked into the courtroom to learn his
punishment for the murder of bianca
devins in july 2019.
her sister spoke to the court as we grew
older that dream turned into a goal
we were going to go to california
together we're going to make memories
now memories is all i have to remember
my sister
bianca was only 17 planning to attend
college to become a psychologist
when brandon clark slashed her throat
after they attended a concert
together in utica new york clark then
posted photos of bianca's lifeless body
on instagram
life as i knew it ended when my
daughter's life was
violently cut short behind was not only
my daughter
but my best friend bianca's mother spoke
of losing her oldest daughter
with the death of your child comes most
unimaginable indescribable pain
a pain that time cannot heal it only
seems to worsen
life without the ankle will never be the
same bianca suffered from mental illness
but her family said she had received
help and was doing well
i hate myself for what i did the judge
questioned clark about why he had tried
to withdraw his guilty plea
clark pleaded guilty last year to
second-degree murder
five months later he tried to withdraw
that plea
the judge denied that request clark now
claims he didn't understand how the
criminal justice system worked
i have a history of mental health and
i feel like just accepting the maximum i
felt like i was
doing myself a disservice that maybe
maybe i could get real help
clark also mentioned wanting to write a
book as a reason for withdrawing that
plea
his words of regret offered little
consolation to bianca devin's family
this man's words trying to apologize
rang very hollow
very hollow he had the opportunity
not to do this crime
and he chose to do it in a callous
manner posting her death photos
videotaping the murder
legislators in new york have actually
introduced what they're calling
brianna's law
that law would actually hold social
media companies
responsible for any graphic content
posted on their sites
brian thanks internet back with us is
terry austin
there are so many aspects of this case
the
gruesome murder the trying to take back
the plea
the sentence that i think just the best
thing to do because i heard
your both your reactions when discuss
this case is just to hear your thoughts
uh terry let's begin with you what did
you think about this case overall
you know this is the type of case where
i think brian it should be more than
just
25 to life hopefully when he comes up
for parole
he will not be granted parole i think
the fact
obviously it was a brutal murder but
it's exacerbated because
he videotaped it and posted it so now we
have
images that the family will have to
think about and you
heard the sister during her victim
impact statement where she talked about
that image comes up in her mind over and
over so
i really am hoping that obviously he is
in prison for the rest of his life
everyone was very upset by this and
that is i think the least they can do as
far as this crime is concerned
it's going to be a very difficult parole
hearing for the defendant if that does
come about i would agree with terry
i don't see a very strong chance of him
getting early release on parole
in the first second or maybe even third
time and janet your thoughts about the
case
yeah i would agree with terry i think
the 25 years
for the parole eligibility is kind of a
gift to him and he probably won't get
that parole you can guarantee that
family will likely be there
to contest that parole hearing or to
contest his release when it happens
absolutely horrifying and i'm just not
so sure that you can rehabilitate
someone
and i strongly believe that people can
be rehabilitated but i am not so sure
that somebody who does something like
this
can be helped to the extent that they
can rejoin society and be
um you know safe and a contributing
member of society who's not going to
put people at risk now terry i know most
people be asking the question
why not the death penalty in new york
state there is not one
um but if this did happen in another
state with the death penalty do you
think that would have been on the table
yes absolutely i do think the death
penalty would have been on the table
and you know i wanted to mention one
thing about getting parole the fact and
this
upset the judge the fact that the
initial plea
was guilty and then he changed his fee
that
really upset the judge and i think when
it comes up for parole
perhaps the family can mention that
issue because that was
very torturous and so hopefully he will
stay in prison i don't think he can be
rehabilitated antoinette was
absolutely right about that and you know
these are terrible circumstances
yeah of course when you go to a parole
hearing that admissions of guilt
is an aspect that they do look at in
terms of the point system that they use
for release
so him maybe going back on that could
potentially have a negative effect on
him
we'll obviously keep eyes on that and
janette terry thank you very much
coming up on law and crime daily the the
georgia killing spree
that left eight dead in three massage
parlors and the motive you didn't see
coming
plus what could it be the mysterious
letter millionaire real estate heir
robert durst tried to have mailed to the
judge but brought to court
should it be part of the court file or
legal analysis next
[Music]
welcome back the trial of millionaire
real estate air robert durst accused of
murdering his best friend is delayed
yet again
robert durst is charged with killing
susan berman at her hollywood hills home
in 2000
he was arrested in 2015 and his trial
began on march 2nd
2020 but it was put on pause after six
days
as a covet-19 pandemic shut down the
country
durst defense has been trying to get a
mistrial declared but the judge repealey
has said
jurors have been admonished not to look
at the news and denied their request
a hearing is now scheduled for april
12th and the trial is set to begin on
may 17th
do you agree to start on may 17th
very good in court durst appeared to
take out a letter
out of his coat jacket he says he mailed
to the judge but was returned
may i give you the letter now
there was return time stamped with
return to sender insufficient address
my apologies attorneys for dirt say they
advise him not to give the judge a
letter
because it will have to be entered into
the court's record for now we won't know
what is in it
meanwhile attorneys continue to argue
over the restarting of the trial we have
been
consistent and objecting to
the length of time that the jury has
been
at recess and at large and we will
continue to object to that additional
senior
you know that's what we're asking for so
we're not saying that we won't start on
may 17th we're just
going to make a record as to why we
think or how we think it should start
so one man's contradiction is another
man's dilemma
terry you've been following this case
closely there are only so many things it
could be
it's something the lawyer doesn't want
durst turning over it could be part of
the record
but it's unlikely something in
furtherance of a crime care to guess
what it could be
only someone like durst could write a
letter to send to the judge
right before the trial is going to start
i think he's going to
underscore what his attorney is already
saying that
making the same jury come back after all
this time is unfair
and i think there's an argument to be
made there i think
because of covet the judge delayed it
but you know start all over pick a new
jury
the other issue brian is i think he
could be saying
that his health is declining because
clearly you can see there
his health looks like it is declining he
mentioned that
you know his hearing is impaired there
you heard his voice
it certainly is also impaired so the
letter might be
saying judge look i need medical
attention maybe take me out of jail
we will see because in april there's
going to be a
hearing so maybe we'll hear something
about it then before the trial starts in
may but
i'm also very curious what that letter
has to say yeah me too
i see the points that you're making the
health
the arguments he could be making those
because maybe he feels i don't know
my lawyers aren't doing a good enough
job so i've got to put my foot forward
but i don't know he's he's a he's a
master manipulator
i've got to feel like it's something
else i hope at some point
we get to see it but as a defense
attorney i don't know the defense
attorney may go back and just rip that
up a little before it gets to see the
judge but
thanks terry when we come back the mode
of law enforcement is saying was behind
the deadly killing spree that left eight
dead
and one wounded in three different
massage parlors
welcome back new information in a spree
of deadly shootings at three spas in
georgia
law enforcement now say they don't
believe the killing of eight people
including six asian women was racially
motivated
twenty-one-year-old robert long is
accused of going on a deadly rampage
near atlanta on tuesday evening
the shootings began in cherokee county
at young's asian massage parlor
the sheriff's office says two asian
women one white woman
and a white man were killed inside a
fifth hispanic male
was injured outside the business and is
recovering at a hospital
we're not sure what his presence was
there and
the other people that were killed at the
location were not going to say whether
they were employees
authorities say long drove into the city
of atlanta and opened fire at two spas
across the street from each other
three people were killed at gold spa and
another killed at aromatherapy
authorities say all four were asian
women we certainly will not
begin to blame victims and as far as we
know in atlanta these are legally
operating businesses that have not
been on on our radar not on the radar
apd
investigators posted screenshots from
surveillance cameras from the business
to social media
they say his family came forward and
identified him to law enforcement
a georgia state patrol officer spotted
long's car on the interstate
and called for backup they initiated the
traffic stop and then
immediately pitted the vehicle after the
vehicle was pitted
the suspect was taken into custody
without further incident and transported
to the chris county jail
long was interviewed by local
authorities along with the fbi
the suspect did take responsibility for
the shootings
he said that early on once we began the
interviews with him
he claims that these and as the chief
said widows is still early but he does
claim that it was not racially motivated
he apparently has an issue what he
considers a
sex fiction and sees these locations as
something that allows him to to um
to go to these places and and it's a
temptation for him that he wanted to
eliminate
deputies recovered a nine millimeter
handgun from long's car
they suspect to be the murder weapon
investigators are also coming through
his social media accounts
he made a comment to that effect that he
was headed to florida
and that he was going to do similar acts
in that state and the issue was that he
wanted to destroy
what had been tempting him it sounds to
me like
these these these locations he sees them
as an outlet for him that some things
that he shouldn't be doing
and that an issue with porn and that
he was attempting to take out that
temptation long is currently in cherokee
county
jail he's expected to go before a judge
on thursday
terry i see why the police don't believe
this is a hate crime his explanation
as we heard just there kind of pulls
that away even though i don't think
that's going to be quite much solace for
the asian american community
but is that fact that it's not racially
motivated gonna make this case any
easier for him
i don't think so i think they're going
to go after him eight people dead that
is a lot of people obviously
look he admitted to the shooting he
admitted that it was
not racially motivated they're going to
investigate anyway
because they have to make sure that it
wasn't racially motivated he actually
said during his
interview that because he was you know
sexually driven he had to kill these
people to
eliminate these motivations that he
might have i think the real
question here brian if they determine
this was
not hate motivated i think they're going
to have to figure out
whether or not he understands the
difference between
right and wrong i think he might try to
assert an insanity defense
and if that is the case i think they're
going to have to look
at this investigation look at the
questioning that occurred
when they arrested him and see what his
answers were
as far as you know what his motivation
was what he was thinking what his state
of mind was at the time he committed
these murders
oh it does it doesn't take a defense
attorney to see what the defense is
going to be here first
is this person competent to stand trial
you're definitely going to see that
examination
the next one as you said his answer by
definition
i have sex issues and therefore i need
to go kill other people to make sure i
don't
that's a mental health defense if i've
ever heard one before
but we're going to keep eyes on that
case and see how it goes terry thank you
for joining us and thank you for joining
us here at law on crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you